it's infectious to take a second to just
acknowledge another human being and do
something nice
as a cmo i thought what an unbelievable
missed opportunity to create
deeper customer engagement and affinity
man super cool
people matter
today's episode of model monsters is
brought to you by tubebuddy
tubebuddy is your best friend on your
road to youtube success
i use it every day on my channel to get
more views and subscribers
automate the boring tasks and split test
my thumbnails and titles i've done over
3
800 split tests which have led to
results like taking this five-year-old
video
that was getting 250 views a day and
just by changing the thumbnail it blew
up to 15
000 views per day you can get started on
tubebuddy for free
at tubebuddy.com evan and there he is
top of the morning how you doing evan
good how are you mark
ah i'm doing great i'm doing great for
my audience before getting into the new
thing you're working on
just give us a quick overview of your
background because you've been you've
been doing this for a while cereal
entrepreneur
tell us tell us your story sure i'd love
to and by the way thanks again for
having me i'm really pumped about being
here with you today
um so just a little bit of background uh
i went into publishing right out of
college i worked for the wall street
journal
found my way out in silicon valley and
just fell in love with technology
moved back to texas and started my first
startup uh and i've been in tech ever
since i sold the media company to zip
davis back in the late 90s during
kinda.com1
uh i was on tv as the computer guy
i was actually host of the show and i
had three or four television programs
um that were broadcast i was a regular
on cnbc
built a media company sold that in the
late 90s and since then had been a
serial entrepreneur around technology
and media
but also i've been a gun for hire i was
the chief marketing officer at mcafee
i led strategy and development at apollo
education and most recently i was
cmo at rackspace uh before jumping off
the wheel
to go back into the dirty business of
entrepreneurship again
so you've got you've got a new company
uh
called grata and and it seems to be like
a mix between
uber and linkedin but for service
workers
and people kind of on the front line so
so tell us about the new project you're
working on
yeah so uh just a quick story i'm a
little bit of a storyteller i think the
context will drive home where this
mashup between an uber rating system a
linkedin for
the long end of the tale of human
capital those working class folks
creates a better mousetrap version of an
indeed or employment opportunity so
i went into home depot one day and i had
one of those experiences that we've all
had right somebody that just
was so incredible with their service
this guy took like an hour and 15
minutes to walk me up and down the
aisles to find everything i needed
that when i checked out i was so
appreciative i made a beeline for that
elevated manager stand because i want to
let them know that this guy frank
was so awesome that i'd never go to a
lowe's for the rest of my life and i'm a
home depot man
and the guy at the counter says oh yeah
yeah frank's great i'm not the manager
i'll pass along have a nice day
just completely blew me off and as i'm
walking to the car i'm thinking first of
all
frank who really kicked butt for me is
not going to get anything for my effort
to try to acknowledge and recognize this
human being
but then as a cmo i thought what an
unbelievable missed opportunity to
create
deeper customer engagement and affinity
you got a customer who's coming to the
counter to tell you how awesome your
store employee is
and you didn't do anything to capture
that experience
and then as a as a user when i got my
car then it was almost
pissed off because i thought i have no
connection with frank
i'm not going to go back in there and
ask for his phone number or his email so
that i can take advantage of this great
service
again and again and again and so that's
when we dug in and realized
while we have a mature ecosystem you and
i do in a linkedin
white collar world in the service sector
there's no connectivity between
employers
customers and the people on the front
lines who are doing all this hard work
and
you know shame on us it took covet for
us to appreciate frontline people
but first and foremost it's about
recognizing the great deeds of these
80 million people who are busting their
hump every day and do great work
so yesterday on youtube there was a
trend in video of
a youtuber youtuber goes into uh like
mcdonald's
and somebody's filming him and he wants
to go
it looks like he's angry uh but he goes
to the front like
hey who made this burger like who made
this burger and eventually they try to
find like the guy who made the burgers
it was
this guy he's like fred you made a
killer burger man i love you
and then everybody starts like clapping
and freaking out this is this is
yesterday trending on youtube um it just
highlights kind of the need for
recognizing somebody who works at
mcdonald's just
like who made my burger i want to say
thank you for making an amazing burger
yeah by the way you just nailed it and
so the sequence just to know how you
capture that right because we're not
most of us aren't going to get out of
the car
and most of us aren't going to scream
who made my friggin burger we're just
not going to do that
so how about a seamless frictionless way
to do that so very simple
we've all been trained to this process
when we
exit an uber of give somebody a
five-star rating
say something nice about that individual
and an optional tip
five-star rating say something nice
optional tip why is that limited to a
couple hundred
uber couple hundred thousand uber
drivers we have 80 million service
sector people changing our tires
bringing us
the barista who's making our drink all
the way down to the guy that's making
our burger
and so that was the whole process why
don't we incorporate that same protocol
on the front end as a way to collect
feedback on these great human beings
that do a great job
and that again allows them to get a
digital record
of all their great deeds because frank
at home depot has no way to memorialize
all these wonderful things that he does
now there's a permanent record in
essence and indeed for frank and those
service sector folks who don't get to
take advantage of the documentation so
again
recognize or record and then the last is
reward
currently we have a billboard with your
venmo our paypal coordinates will have
full
integrated ach day ch in about 60 days
so you never have to leave the app
so you can tell that person dude you did
a great job
thank you you're awesome here's a buck
or two if you want to do that but again
to create a frictionless way for us to
reward and recognize
that's cool so so you need to have the
companies to obviously opt in on this
and and roll it out no no quite the
contrary so
business models real simple just like
linkedin that guy working at mcdonald's
could go in and fill out a profile
they're automatically populated in our
database
and the next time somebody comes in and
wants to give him or her
a rating in grata they're already in
there other employees can
come along no one has to have permission
from the employer and it doesn't cost a
thing
where we get companies to sign up we
have a b2b sas component of this
where when large lot retailers let's
just stay with home depot
if home depot were to want to get the
performance data
and all the analytics that come from
that customer feedback plus all the
customer engagement opportunities that
come from hooking up
employees with customers they can pay a
small fee of 99 cents per month per
employee for the data but the service
itself
is absolutely free so if i'm i'm fred or
i'm evan working on home depot you know
my my business tanks and i got to go to
get a job at home depot
uh do i wear a badge or like how am i
being
how do you find me yeah so right now if
you were the first person at home depot
you'd have to do
it it'd be a viral experience you'd
actually by the way if i did a good job
for you to let me know
how i did on grata and right and
somebody could go in and download and by
the way you authenticate with facebook
or google coordinates
you're up and running in seconds that's
number one but as companies start to
embrace this
we've had some large box retailers who
are not only excited about doing an
inscription or but they basically say to
all their employees please download this
app
we're going to promote it at checkout
but even on the point of sale system the
idea that you can see that ubiquitous
grata icon press a button immediately
spin through an infinite loop
like a dating app almost of faces and
names
find the person who waited on you and
give them a five star and some
commentary
you're going to see it integrated on
point of sale too so we're in the
infancy
we're just starting to roll out but we
hope that one day again it is as
commonplace to see that icon as a good
housekeeping seal
or a a checkout cart icon well isn't
that as easy as having that having the
person
just wear a badge with with a keyboard
that can be scanned in
sure we could very easily deploy via qr
code for every individual employee and
take you right
to their profile again that will take
some integration and participation from
the retailer or the business but just to
sign up today
you could go tomorrow evan if you wind
up at home depot or at mcdonald's
and you could start harvesting great
feedback from customers that love what
you do
well you're getting you're getting lots
of love in the chat people are saying
dude this man is visionary
freaking brilliant oh all right let me
write this down for my wife
do quick screen caption for me because i
want to show her later
uh that's great hey one last point on
this because i don't want to miss
we're talking a lot about the benefit
for these employees
don't underestimate the value for users
the fact that we can all have a
personal almost a personal angie's list
of go-to folks that always treat us
right that always do a good job for us
where did my hairdresser barbara move to
where that hvac guy that used to work
for us at the plumbing company where is
he now because he was awesome
the ability to stay connected with
people that take care of us gives an end
user
a lot of motivation above and beyond
just rewarding people but last point
last story and i'll make it very brief
this whole idea in your mcdonald's
was so perfect i got to go find that
youtube video uh
i went into starbucks one day and i got
back in my car
and the thought crossed my mind that
that woman that works in the front
counter takes such great care of me that
i got out of my car
got back in line waited my turn i got
back to the counter she said
oh mark i'm sorry was there something
wrong with your coffee i said no
you know what i just realized i never
stopped to tell you how much i
appreciate you you're always in a great
mood my coffee's always spectacular
i put three dollars in the tip jar for
my four dollar latte whatever
it says once you know i appreciate you
wish you started crying
now of course i feel terrible all the
people in line are probably going who's
the old guy that made the young girl at
the counter start crying for goodness
sakes right
no good deed goes unpunished and she
said i just want you to know how much i
appreciate that
that's why we do this we love working
with people we love being a part of your
day and i appreciate you taking that
minute
can i tell you something that day at
lunch i grossly over tipped on our lunch
meal
the rest of the day i was on cloud night
it's infectious to take a second
to just acknowledge another human being
and do something nice and god knows in
the environment we've been in
for the last handful of years we could
use use a little more kindness and a
little more recognition and praise so
i think the gratitude component of this
uh there's something in there that i
hope that people will respond to
what's the feedback been from companies
on the tipping idea
yeah uh a little hot and cold so as you
can imagine there's some environments
like
do i really want my employees in a big
box retailer competing for tips
so uh that there's optionality then if
we're doing an enterprise
sas deployment for a large retailer
they're not always as comfortable
with that so i think that's a very good
point
in smaller retail environments an
alternative say in a restaurant to
traditional cash tipping
it's just one more avenue by which they
can connect
those payments to their employees the
other side that they're super pumped
about
is the idea that for affinity programs
and loyalty and rewards
if i care so much that i take the time
to vote on your employees and let's be
honest this is kind of a
digital version of a customer comment
card with a lot of cool stuff on the
back end
but nobody ever figured out how to do
this and and there is no
data harvesting on last mile customer
facing employees full stop you can do it
for mid management senior board of
directors
nothing on the front line so the data is
what's so important to companies
because especially postcovid one thing
that we've all acknowledged we don't
know what
retail and service looks like after we
go through this
crisis but we know one thing whether
it's low touch or no touch there'll be
less human to human interaction and
and we have just got to get it right the
first time unless we lose
uh and get disintermediated from our
customers so uh
people matter and is the data public
like
i can go in and see the ratings on
different people who work at this
starbucks i'm about to go to
guys even better than that you walk into
starbucks and the apps can immediately
show you every employee stack rank
whoever's got the highest rep
score comes in first so especially like
restaurants oh i want to sit in his
section or her section
so yeah we gamify it in that those
people get that recognition to know that
they're really good at their job and by
the way
they should be recognized so all the
behind the scenes data
uh is not public depending on the
preference of the user so i can hide my
comments if i want
but just think about this and use your
example of starbucks
if i have 50 customers that gave me a
grata and said i did a wonderful job
two things changed the entire dynamic of
my work life
one i've documented all my good deeds
and my successes as part of my resume
so the next time i go to interview for a
job i don't just show my resume but i
say
hold on addendum let me show you page
two here's 50 customers
and the great things that they say about
my service yeah
boom completely different scenario but
number two
that barista has their book of business
or their customer contacts
as part of their record as well that's
another change so now they can say
i also have 50 loyal customers that i'm
going to ping and tell them by the way
i'm now working down the street at
dunkin donuts so you talk about
empowering
folks who are on the front line you
deserve your good deeds to be
memorialized you deserve co-ownership in
that book of business that you helped
build
and if you document and record those two
things your value in the workplace goes
up
full stop i love it um
i'm trying to think who's who's the
forward-facing
business owners who will take you up on
this because there's a lot of people who
live in fear
who when you say stuff like that they're
like oh my god i'm going to lose all my
employees i don't want to be head hunted
and
you know i mean they might be dealing
with that already on on like
like you said linkedin and everything
else but i don't know that starbucks
wants to roll that out and like lose
their baristas to some new company
like how so many people will live off
fear-based decisions
with the power of this technology who
are the visionary businesses you're
partnering with to kind of bring this to
life
well uh i don't think it's quite as
draconian as you would present because i
think that
i think the lion's share of companies
really certainly the progressive ones
recognize that talent has got to be
recognized or it will naturally
gravitate out anyway and those companies
that really care about their employees
are investing in their future and
investing in their recognition uh one
interesting data point and there's a lot
of hr studies along these lines but
qsrs or those front-line employees
one out of five will leave your business
in the next 12 months
one out of five of your top performers
let me qualify
20 percent of your top performers will
leave not over compensation
not over conflict with a manager lack of
recognition and appreciation
so there is a fundamental cost involved
in not recognizing these human beings
forget the human component
and the fact that it's the right thing
to do there's a ben impact to your p l
to acknowledge and praise them
number two we have a much better chance
of keeping our top people if we're
investing in them
and acknowledging their good work then
if we cower and hide behind the corner
and cross our fingers they don't leave
and we won't invest in them and i think
successful businesses understand that
but there's some that will operate out
of fear
i'll tell you one thing that's helped a
lot covid has helped
shall we say i don't want to say shame
but certainly it's brought
pressure on the c-suite and
organizations to acknowledge
those human beings that are bagging our
groceries and delivering our food that
we
now all realize we're a lifeline to this
economy and to us as humankind so
there's a
motion in play right now completely
unintended we started this long before
covet
that has organizations trying to fulfill
their pledges
as they've all stepped up to say my
frontline folks matter and i want to do
something about it so we're saying well
okay now's the time to do that we've got
tools to help facilitate that
let's put action behind the words what
what
motivated you to do this aside from it
being a good idea and
and uh you know want to be back in the
entrepreneur game
why this business over something else
beyond just the strategic
reasons for it yeah i could get a little
personal i will tell you that i'm i'm
causal on a lot of items or issues
around
uh social justice and and equity etc um
and just quite frankly this motion
touched my heart i spent some time in
apollo education
in strategy and we were working in large
part on next generation learning systems
and they were all about
a vocational outcome on the back end how
do we
better people's lot in life and how we
backfill quite frankly part of the
links of the chain that linkedin was not
servicing and so
i spent a fair amount of time immersed
in this idea about helping human beings
better themselves and i i teach i'm
full-time faculty one day a week at the
university of texas at austin where i
teach both
technology marketing and
entrepreneurship so i've been i've
spent one day a week giving back on
trying to groom and
and teach and i spend time mentoring it
capital factory our largest accelerator
in texas it's just kind of a core uh
quite frankly of of trying to be causal
i didn't have it at 30
something i have it at 50 something and
i never had an opportunity to have my
hands
on dials this big that could
simultaneously
impact so many people's lives uh in such
a positive way
but at the same time was wholly
consistent with driving
top-line growth and solving business
needs that
again this idea that was good for the
soul and good for the balance sheet
you don't get the opportunity to see the
juxtaposition
of those two often and when i saw that
it was within our sites and the
massive site of the need which is a
multi-billion dollar market
um i i knew this had to had to do i had
to do it
are any of these frontline workers
unionized
uh certainly certainly depending on
certain parts of the country that's
much more of a northeast and and
illinois and to some degree
a california phenomenon but um but yeah
but i wouldn't
i wouldn't know the breakout between
union and non i think is that is that
just an easier path in for you to work
with the unions and say
hey like tell your employer we want to
use this as part of our next
you know negotiation you know that's a
great idea i go honestly i hadn't even
thought about that
that's actually a great idea i hadn't
thought about union approach the closest
thing i had to that was i had a really
smart entrepreneur
who has worked in the public safety uh
fire and police domain
and he coined a great term he said mark
this is the anti-body cam
this is an opportunity for police
officers to engage the community
and community citizens to give direct
feedback
in essence flipping that body cam idea
which i thought was brilliant and so
we started an effort to try to explore
how do we go through local
state and federal to explore uh
security and police as an opportunity
but i think your idea about
finding your way into uh into unions is
a
is a great one i spoke to the head of
the the dallas restaurant association
which made became an introduction to the
texas restaurant association so there's
a lot of groups like that by industry
vertical
where they were very much in favor of
endorsing this to all their members
i love it so so for people watching like
what do you want
what do you want them to do you want
people to to download it you want people
to go
to their starbucks and say hey you
should get on here because they want to
recognize you like what
are is it launched yet can people get
involved like we want them to do
yeah so brand new so just launch so uh
what i'd like honestly is
all of the above so if you're if you
work with an organization that could
deploy this as an enterprise tool
again there's a free version and a paid
version we're happy to help you with
either so
we'd love to do a deployment inside your
organization most importantly it's just
the evangelism of the
of the technology download the app uh
the url is gratapro
pro.com but uh download the app you can
find it on itunes google play
and start play with it upload your own
resume your most recent job will then
populate the database we use
google apis and geocoordinates to pull
all this together but just
to get people to start using it go into
your favorite restaurant tell your
server that you're fond of hey
i'd love for you to download this app
because i'd like to give you a five-star
rating and go back and show your boss
how much we think of you and it's how
you can start racking up your own gratis
we just gotta start spreading the gospel
of what this thing can do
and um so that's kind of our next step
we've just launched as
a i mean you're hot off the presses five
days
cool and for the youtube audience we'll
link that in the description as well so
you can go
one click go check it out um if somebody
is
watching and they are one of these
service workers
how do how do you recommend they have
the conversation with their boss to
bring it to
the company i think they should download
it first and just start using it and hit
up a few customers you know we all have
some friendly customers i used to own a
bunch of restaurants
and so uh there was nothing that would
that would
warm my heart more than if you walked
into my restaurant evan said hey mark
good to see you whatever brush me off
is samantha working i want to sit in her
section that personal relationship
that you can get with one of my
employees transcends my brand my menu my
location everything right
and so most of us have some of those
personal relationships go in sit in the
section say samantha you're awesome hey
i want you to download this app it's
pretty cool let's see and then by the
way if samantha gets three or four
grottas and can go back to her boss and
say
look what my customers are saying about
me everybody else is going to want to do
it too
right so we're all a little bit
competitive and other servers are going
to be going like wow
oh and you also got some tips directly
from this then it's like
lights out meatball let me in so uh just
spread the gospel share with people
about what we're doing
and how they can get involved and just
download it and use it
do you see it eventually integrating
with google reviews or yelp
where people can go look at the reviews
on the store but then there's also like
grota top people incorporated down the
side
i'll tell you where very close to that
uh where i really see it
deployed is on uh job sites let's just
take indeed for example
uh currently if i go to indeed to look
up a bartender and i want to find
bartenders for my restaurant
i've got lots of queries around
geography work history et cetera so i
can kind of narrow the scope
what i don't have is one single solitary
qualitative input i have no way to stack
rank and know
who's really good and who's really great
and who's not as good
so where i really see this is i see
people taking their
uh their gratis score as part of their
resume i can see looking up one day
in uh indeed and saying you know what
i'm looking for bartenders i want them
within three miles of my restaurant and
i want them to have a 4.5 out of 5 star
rating or better i really want the top
of the top which by the way democratizes
opportunity because i'm going to pay
more for the best one so
that's where i think that we'll start to
see the rankings i think we'll see it on
the
on job sites first and i think frankly
that's really where it belongs
because that's where we can take that
history and empower that human being
to have a better outcome professionally
inside of a restaurant or starbucks how
much
how much different pay structure is
there for
most people yeah i can't speak to every
single organization
i can tell you that you know so many
restaurants let's just let's just take a
stereotypical example
uh in the state of texas we pay 219 an
hour plus tips so that's kind of your
minimum wage
um the dynamic is what happens when a a
server comes in that is so
exceptional with their background and
they say privately hey i'm making
for an hour plus tips at my existing job
that's where a lot of the
the pull comes in so i think the ability
just speaking from my own experience boy
i would pay
significantly more than 219 an hour if i
knew how to find
the really good ones so i think
the there's some elasticity in that pay
how
great it is it's still going to be
incremental compared to the tips
unless you get into kitchen staff that
can make 10 15 an hour and get this is
geography i'll use texas basis
kitchen line cooks soup chefs et cetera
10 15
an hour you might see those migrate up
to 12 13 on the bottom
up to closer to 20. but again um if we
had a way
to separate the quality from the knot
and
and that's what this does for the first
time ever yeah
man super cool i learned something new
today i'm gonna i'm gonna check it out
if you guys want to follow mark
uh do you have a your own account
because this is this is grab a dot pro
on instagram to check that out
uh is that the best place it is website
pro
you yes those are the two best places
and again i uh
i'm very active on linkedin as well so
that will be the two best thanks
cool and is it is it if somebody's not a
frontline service worker
is it still something for them or or no
go to linkedin
absolutely look you know if you're in
the linkedin professional class or not
if you're job scope
if you're changing tires at discount
tire you're wholly uncomfortable with
having a linkedin profile it's just not
your environment
i think most people know which one they
belong in but if you're in a service
sector hourly customer facing role and
linkedin's not right for you
uh we have a home for you i love it mark
bunting grotta dot pro
so pumped uh you could join us here
today share some wisdom and i'm super
excited to see how this all
works out man evan i really appreciate
it thanks for the time and the
enthusiasm
awesome thanks man okay if you want to
change your life in 30 days check out my
free training right here below
or if you want to see the one-on-one i
did with dean grazio so you check the
video right there next to me
i think you'll enjoy them continue to
believe and i'll see you there